the republican jewish coalition
conference is being held at the venetian
it's an opportunity for top gop
contenders to speak out and pitch their
bids for the upcoming election madison
kimbrough joins us live at the donation
with the details on this madison
yeah presidential contenders here at the
conference in good spirits tonight
hoping that the republican party can
take back control of the country in the
next coming year
from this point forward we will all
resolve to do our part to win back the
house the senate
governorships across america in 2022.
coming off of tuesday's electoral
successes former vice president pence
along with several other republican
political officials joined in saturday
night to celebrate victory as virginia
republicans officially took control of
the state house of delegates the rjc is
a chance for the jewish community and
republican decision makers to come
together and since its cancellation last
year due to the pandemic it's the first
time it's been back since former
president donald trump lost the election
and president joe biden won office south
carolina senator lindsey graham pleased
with how the gop is moving forward i've
never felt more optimistic than i am
right now about us taking back the
senate it starts with great candidates
if we don't take back the house
nobody blame but us
this year the rjc paid tribute to
sheldon adelson the chief executive
officer of las vegas sands corporation
who passed away this past january
adelson was known to be a major funder
of the republican party pro-israel
causes and his las vegas properties have
long hosted the rjc conventions
and other key political figures here
republican political figures we have
nikki haley kellyanne conway
ted cruz and doug christie all in
attendance the rjc concludes tomorrow
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now